III wrote on I saw I saw someone share a
photo that I read shared on Instagram
the other day of a composer who is Greek
who has had pretty severe muscular
dystrophy and has basically been
bedridden and on my soul intensive care
kind of support life's literal life
support for essentially his whole life
and he still writes music every day and
I have a photo of him lying in bed where
he's got this great big sort of our you
know arm holding up a monitor so he can
lie on his back looking straight up and
right music and I thought it was so
amazing and I my friend that posted I
said you know I'm gonna I'm gonna steal
this in reshare because what an amazing
you know me you know when it's tempting
to look around and say oh man how
annoying that I can't get my normal
supply of avocados or whatever you know
here's someone who is like [ __ ] it I I
am late I'm a hair's breadth from death
and I'm still doing what I feel wired to
do and and I got a little bit of
pushback when I cuz somebody wrote on
their like you know oh I can't I'm
disabled it's the worst [ __ ] ever
and I said well wait a minute
I said you're allowed to grieve like a
shock to your system you're allowed to -
exactly to your point it doesn't matter
if you're the billionaire in the castle
or somewhere vaseline still living
castles I feel like they probably don't
okay well it's it's very politics
appreciative to me yeah to me it's less
in LA thing unless your name is William
Randolph Hearst and otherwise it's much
more of a British thing but yeah so guys
make sense yeah I think it's I think
it's okay to feel stressed without
worrying about the fact of you know my
stress doesn't map to the greater stress
that's possible because it's so it's so
unfair like to our own emotions you know
yeah I also think the amount of pressure
we put on people to not complain about
trivial things when sometimes
complaining about a trivial thing is is
the healthy thing to do it's all right
yeah I mean I mean here right now you
see people being like oh well people are
dying it suck
that you can't do whatever like you'll
Computers not walking but people are
dying Emily yeah but like while while
there are larger issues that we need to
pay a lot of respect to I don't think
that because someone else has something
less than you you shouldn't be allowed
to a agreements is like I think that's a
balance to be missin interesting I I can
resonate with that because I think that
it is I think chiropractor tell me once
that there was like a my neck was [ __ ]
up whatever reason is like have you been
in a car wreck and it's like no and he
said that this is just a culmination of
several minor trauma so you could step
off the curb wrong and you do that
enough times and it can give you the
same type of injury that you would have
if you were in a major automobile
accident I was like that's crazy so I
think it's the same thing as like I need
to complain if I'm way out but could not
complain but I need to I think a lot of
you saw this area grievances about you
know Austin's avocados or or whatever it
is so that we understand that those
things are important like you said Mike
it's like our our lives have been
disrupted that's okay for us to kind of
call out yeah there was a there was a
guy within our community robo-ninja
shark super good dude epic epic beard
and he said he was sharing with him or
with a shirt on his twitter like a story
about his wife and he said that they
went through just a horrific medical
situation and he said that I realized
that what we were experiencing was the
human condition and I found comfort in
that because if it was the human
condition that meant that all of the
generations before me had experienced
this and I wasn't alone in it it was
like and they got through it so I could
get through it was like yeah I know
think we need to maybe a worse version
of it too yeah we don't need to we don't
need to be relativistic like it's
avocados guy probably knows his surgery
is not as bad as avocados sounds like a
Indy mobile game it is now coming yeah
coming this summer coming one
I always come back to I don't know how
it is in the u.s. I see him it's similar
in the UK they're basically like every
you know I remember I remember as a kid
being really worried because I had
dandruff right my hair I was really
self-conscious about it was the worst
thing ever really marries me and I
remember like you know you're constantly
as a kid you I was constantly reminded
like seeing adverts on TV for anti
dandruff shampoo that's I know you make
but I thought it really bothered me a
rebonding but as a teenager but as a
teenager I think I must have been like I
guess I was like 15 it was just this
moment of Epiphany where it's like wait
a minute
if there's a commercial for an
anti-dandruff shampoo and that means
lots of people have dandruff and I'm
probably not it weird right like
probably this is unlike it was not an
advert like at 2:00 a.m. in the morning
this was not a primetime TV show right
there must be a market place and I
remember I remember this thought process
a 15 year old like blowing my mind yeah
I feel like I have a very similar 15
year old thought process along a very
similar line where I remember a girl
telling me that she thought her cubs
were too big and she was insecure about
it and I had this moment of no one else
is ever going to notice that I have
never noticed that the fact that you
hate that is insane and then I was like
what are all the things that I hate
about the way that I look that no one
has ever [ __ ] thought about that only
I care about that's absolutely a thing
like if I see someone who has dandruff I
don't care I'm like completely
indifferent it's not a thing I have a
look at and get you know dandruff like
it just washes over my head is something
that doesn't matter but to someone who
has it it's the worst thing in the world
and I think then I got that perspective
of someone's cobs being too big and I
was like how could you care about that
it was like I'm sure there are a million
things about me that other people have
never even thought about that I'm like
oh I hate that we're little prisoners -
right we're all prisoners of Mines my
question is when you paid attention
where her cars ridiculously large
lovingly time super coffee would you
know I think because the best punch
light to this story is and I looked at
them and I was horrified yes there was a
director that I worked with her name is
Amanda Wyatt she's awesome and when we
were working on those Arkham origins the
engineer because if he hears you're sat
on the booth you know and you know the
engineer there and you have typically
someone from the studio and a wife who
was a voice-over director and so Amanda
gets a very company rend and she's a
great director and she has a tendency to
as you're singing your lines to kind of
go along with you and if she doesn't
like married life she's doing every time
that's turned out my camera when I'm
directing or the video yeah yeah when we
were making Arizona Circle the comedy
sketch show a funhouse produced and
directed one of the directors Chris any
time and he would watch a scene from
behind the camera you would see him like
screw up his face like again sorry audio
was nice but he'd be like but you
wouldn't be acting as extremely as he
was projecting with his own face you
just have to know where this yeah very
very funny someone managed to record him
doing it wins when I hear music I like
my face kind of contorts until wins just
instinctively and agile is amazing when
you're doing like a live record and
you're just in front of an like you know
amazing musician musicians start playing
singing and you're stood there as the
guy who's you know directing the whole
thing going you know I maintain that
like directing and performance are the
two most physically taxing jobs under
direction as well like I am so tired
after a recording session really just
from directing it well because you're
paying so much attention cuz it's my job
when I'm directing someone to be hearing
every syllable out of their mouth and we
never do that we never listened so
intently because I have to listen to
what they're doing I have to be thinking
about what I need in the context of the
game I used to be working out like okay
on this take I got that thing and that
they hear enough space between his
breath and take but if I need her
it's all about stuff you're doing
something that I recorded for a game
where I had to die in a car accident
very difficult a big big amount of
trouble doing that and they were like I
just don't believe that you're dying and
I was like well I don't know how that
I'm dying like it was a very tough thing
for me to do and I ended up asking
someone to come in the room with me so I
could physically push them I was like if
I have something that I feel like is a
force that I can like physically like
let out anguish on then I think I can
probably do this but just like sitting
in this chair trying to stay still not
having anything to do to try to pretend
but I'm trying to get out of this car
while like I'm dying was it just video
yeah it's just be yet oh dude this such
a challenge it was really it was really
tough the hardest one I've done so far
is a game with this multiple choice and
one line I'm laughing I'm happy and then
the next line I'm crying and then the
next line I'm furious and and I found
that actually like extremely taxing
often even though that was only maybe of
two hours that session after I was done
I was more dreams than I would be from
working eight hours a day at a
convention you know that like that like
put this whole new perspective on vo to
me where I was like I had to change
emotion so rapidly so dramatically as
quickly as I could so they can get
through it it was so taxing like I don't
I don't know how how you do that Troy
like frequently like it was so hard I
think oh so you don't have to do it that
way this this will go to like I think a
I'll probably be teeing up Mike Biffle
for a good piggybacking for this but
structuring structuring your scenes in
such a way that understand that about
actors that actors are finite resources
they're people that have limitations and
and being able to go okay maybe we don't
do the happiest scene and the saddest
scene right next to each other and
depending upon the actor they may be
like no I like going from those extremes
that's what's important about having a
good actor director relationships where
they go
I know Troy well enough to know that
he's probably gonna want to just dive
straight in to the the biggest scene so
we can really understand who this
character is and that will
walk backwards to like the simpler stuff
so III wouldn't say this so much
revelatory about you as it is also about
those people ultimately the director's
job in my opinion in a voice recording
our performance recording session and
across the game development is to
facilitate like getting the value
because in that environment you're the
person doing the work you're the person
generating content for the game it's
their job to facilitating and it depends
like Troy says different actors are
different the joke I always make about
Troy behind his back is Troy will often
do his best takes while he's in the
booth waiting for you to stop paying
attention to he's doing and genuinely
there are takes I have of Troy in John
wick in future things at all like
absolutely just I couldn't quite catch
what was anything but that are like
they're there in there because he just
he he he I see I don't find by himself
he jumps in but but then there's an
another voice actor I was working with
this week who is like is doing what you
suggest along or ask for it and that's
the first thing you asked as a director
is she rock to you there how do you like
to work yeah and I've got I'm this actor
specifically was like can we order this
by intensity can we start with the stuff
I'm still so new you know that there's a
you shouldn't be you shouldn't be asking
they should be offering you the
opportunity and and and paying attention
to what you're doing so another example
is an actor I worked with recently who
was like it was it came in it was very
kind of going homes like however you
want to do it I want to work how do you
want to work and I was like thank you
and we start working very quickly I
realized that actor needed to run
scripts like back and forth rather than
doing kind of a lot if the time when
you're recording games you loop over one
line I rely and I realized like they
weren't they needed that they were
willing to ask for it and it's my job to
go try this way and then we just did
that and I got a bad performance they
were more comfortable and we'll probably
work with me again as a result Rowley
having a bad experience probably a part
of being a director in that capacity is
figuring out its empathy yeah your
empathy is a huge asset but I don't
imagine that everyone has that as an
acid or
resource they can pull on it yeah and
they need to get out then they need to
stop wasting the time of the actor only
about that that seems like a kind of a
minimum requirement right like yeah they
do this job you should be able it's like
the whole discussion of pain so I don't
really you know I'm kind of colors and
brushes it's the same with music like if
if you can't hear you know the
difference between a you know violin and
a trumpet
what was that I very quietly so it's not
Paul focus decided to open up my
biscuits to dip in my delicious cup of
coffee and I think what happened was my
girlfriend understanding that I'll be a
crinkly sound and they disrupted the
podcast pre opened the bag so when I
lifted it up the end that was open the
two biscuits loud leaving that crumbled
on the floor and I have no biscuits I'm
so sorry for your loss clear you're
allowed to feel bad about that even
though there's worse promises and also
that was the best descriptor for the
audio group perfectly i i i care about
those listening i also love how much
mileage we've gotten out of something
that was designed to not pull focus well
terms of my career austin that's great
how's it you're talking about the act of
directing musicians being apathetic is
the director of musicians yes yeah well
yeah they were just in this there's just
it's always interesting to hear how
directly some things correlate the one
that specifically jumped out from a
moment earlier was when you were saying
how like i'll when both of you were
talking about how draining it can be for
something that's seemingly less work
than other things like eight hours at a
convention is actually easier than two
hours of super intense performance that
you know conducting on the person I
definitely have a thing where yeah
sorry to cut you off I am you know I did
ten hour straight on-camera days at e3
at IGN doesn't bother me at all like I
can do that forever even have that with
fun house where I'll be like
I could make five videos all day every
day but they can only really get away
with two so for whatever reason being on
camera does not exhaust me at all I
don't know how but then like just that
one particular session I'm not allowed
to talk about the game or anything yet
but I was just so what I liked was it
was nothing unrelated to my QuickBooks I
don't think in Austin and I said this a
lot no one is out there doing anything
to farias like look how terrible of a
session I can run everyone is genuinely
typically I believe trying to do their
best
yeah the problem interests and when it's
like you said like by and large the
people that are put into those positions
are are done out of necessity it's like
you are free you go do this right you
said that you wanted to do this so now
go do it
it's a thing that I really um greatly
admire Neil druckmann for is that he
wasn't originally the director for I
think he was the lead designer on The
Last of Us and he was the writer but he
wasn't the creative director and he
wasn't the performance director either
he just we originally started off with
the different directors Gordon hunts who
also directed all of the Uncharted and
so it was like true deal so you can't
became Gordon hunt to do this when
Gordon came in because it's not
uncharted if it feels like this tonal he
needs to be different you know so then
they were like let's start looking at
other directors and they ran the gamut
they went to all the usual suspects in
town they started throwing out different
names and then finally new it's like
where we got a we got a shoot and
they're like finally why don't you do it
and so he showed up on set he called me
before it's like I'm gonna be there is
there anything you need and he took the
time to go and he went to acting classes
he went to directing classes he absorbed
all of this material and completely
devoted himself to the process and then
owned the fact it was like this is my
first time that's why he's one of the
greatest directors I've ever worked with
is because he allowed himself freedom to
fail and he went into it with the
thought of look if I'm if
not right for this I'll get out of the
way if there's someone that can do it
better I'll get another way I'm going
into this to learn and if I if that is
my intention
then I'll never fail because I'll always
learn he's brilliant but were there just
on that I don't I'm not trying to pry
for for dirty laundry so I trust your
judgement and answering this but were
there any like blunders on his part that
in those early days that became kind of
teachable moments that you kind of
overcame where it was like ah there's
that you know because when he said he
really owned I've never done this before
did did it sort of then cut to three
days later of like oh well I'm never
doing that again kind of thing like was
there sort of supreme [ __ ] in other
words that that that everybody was able
to sort of say okay now we've learned
some things I think that well I I know
I'm sure he would answer this question
differently I know one that he says is
the Sarah scene I feel like it was my
doing and he feel like it was his he was
like I should have known sooner that it
wasn't working as opposed to trying and
trying and trying and trying and
eventually giving up and then having to
come back in and reshoot it and get a
much much better performance out of it
but it was Neill understanding that was
experiential you know you'll get there
until you actually do it you can't
cognitively academically understand that
until you're in that situation and he
had to go through the trial fire the
difference though is nobody knew it
nobody ever felt like it was this
colossal [ __ ] there was not one scene
we all walked away as like this kid
doesn't know the [ __ ] he's doing and we
always felt like dude he really knows
what his direction it's like he has a
clear focused and he could be walking up
and he has a very specific manner about
doing things he takes notes he's right
there in the scene with you he's not off
you know behind video village cheese was
typically right there he's watching and
he comes into everyone individually and
he stands and he he will kind of rock on
the outsides of issues
and he'll start requesting this a look
at his notes and remembers like he what
was this what was this what did you do
question in this moment he always gets
brings you into the process so it's
never just someone going angrier louder
softer it's always he specifically goes
through the process of not asking a
result-oriented
question and making sure that when he
asks you the question he's genuinely
open to your answer as opposed to how
can I manipulate you today my answer
making you feel heard rather than being
actually heard yeah and I've seen him go
oh cool yeah just write that as opposed
to just an okay that's not the right
answer how about you how that aspect of
it doesn't really matter all to the
orchestra conducting side of directional
very strikes right there's no no I don't
even it's not about me I'm saying I
don't think that that's strategy even
holds because because I have been that
guy so many times where I may have told
the story before I can't remember but
I've been on the podium so many times
where we do a performance and I'll be
like you know that was that was solid
but like like let's say I'm just making
this up but like let's say it was on
Abzu so it's like I'll say to them you
know the thing is the colors feel like
they should be a little muted because
it's underwater there's kind of a
wavering nature and I'll get into all
this and I'm practically like pulling
out books of poetry and then the
musician someone will eventually raise
their hand go so you want it quite or
louder
you a question on the the comic-con
panel we did Austin where I was like
what's the sound for this game and you
gave me this like very long floaty spiel
and I was like I thought you just say
like synth but it was beautiful and
poetic even in the way you described it
that I was like yes it is poetic it that
like it's one of those I see it is I'm
trying to I'm like making concentric
circles like this vulture trying to kind
of find or like when a dog is sort of
trying to decide to sit down and
seemingly just endlessly scouting the
same location sometimes I feel like that
where I'll be giving this elaborate
description what I could have just said
a touch louder and we'll be golden
because the musicians I mean that's the
fundamental differences I guess the
orchestra is used to acting as an
ensemble so they're relying on you to be
very much directing them as opposed to
appealing to them as seventy individual
artists being like I want to hear your
take violin three chairs seven like you
know what I mean that kind of because I
and that's one a lot of you see them as
sheep as a result they're like it's a
who as I say and it's like well I don't
wanna go there but at the same time yeah
we gotta find them you don't mind the
balance we we like I had it again like
something I'm recording in a moment
which is people yeah
the thing I'm recording moment like wait
why will they have been announced by the
time this podcast is up I do not want to
assume that so we can talk about it now
said Michael I don't want to be very
careful to see how something goes
terribly wrong money to have just a
little bleep of like effort Aurora
but like recording something like an all
I've had one actor will have taken a
particular because I because that's the
other thing is that indie budgets you're
often recording people individually
rather than being able to do the lavish
kind of performance have we have so
jealous where you have multiple people
in the same room so I'll have had like
an act and make a choice in the previous
recording session and at that point you
do sometimes have to be and I'm always
try always just try and be honest I let
people have like their say where they
where I can
but it's something like know the guy
record yesterday yelled that line that
goes into your line see you have to read
it as if you're freaking out someone was
shouting because he's not here and I
can't really afford that stuff like when
after-party came out and I heard my
voice lines for that I when I record it
for that I didn't know what the
player-character sounded like and while
I'm like fine with that performance I
was like I wish I had known he was that
sassy if I hadn't known how much sense
he was giving me I would have responded
with more sass yeah sometimes the
scheduling you just can't you do have to
have people work blind I always try and
like let people hear the stuff around
them but you can't always I think the
key thing where I think I think the
unified thing here between what Austin's
saying between what choice saying about
Neil is it reminds me of I think I might
be involving about my favorite moments
in Star Trek is um a card and it's I
think it's Deanna Troi beam down to a
planet and generous is which way should
we go and because you know we should go
that way and they go that way and a
couple of minutes as Sean Connery Sean
Connery is in their lab a place I saw at
Roy's face and I was like something's
coming see 50% of the call or
professional voice actors the other 50%
of us have to make do right but yeah so
I so I am so so couple minutes later
they're lost and the Android tone SIM
card says you said you said this way
he's like I didn't know where I was
meant to be going but I'm the captain I
had to say something and that's the big
thing that I always come back to is like
leadership is often you don't know the
right answer you just have to give a
direction you just have to go in a path
and if it works out great and then one
thinks you're clever and if it doesn't
work out at least you will you failed in
a direction mice actus right it's like
you have to make a choice it's better
than just not making any choice even if
they were trying change there was a
great moment I may have told the story
before - there was a great moment when
we were auditioning for Henry and Sam
and a kid that was gonna come in and
play Sam was going through the scene and
and Gordon
was actually directing at the time but I
got to watch how he worked it was
brilliant and he pulls the kid over the
signs like me ask you question what do
you think he wants in this scene the kid
thought about for a second and he goes
he was his trust he goes yes she told me
that yeah it goes to the scene again and
the kid was brilliant he actually get
into getting the part and he walks out I
looked at Gordon I was like I disagree
yes hmm is that I disagree with that I
don't think he wanted his you said trust
I think it was a trust thing as a
respect he was like we're talking about
it's like in the sea he told him is like
I didn't care what he said because it's
an ice cream I just needed him to make a
choice and I think that to into speak to
your thing that you're talking about a
lot I was like oh god if I had heard it
that way welcome to the actor's
conundrum you would always the best take
you'll ever give is the one you gave in
the car or like like Mike said when they
weren't rolling he like off you just got
that one that was the best one it was
inspired it was organic or whatever but
so immediately that wasn't insult Troy
you always refer yourself getting ready
when I'd read out and and I've captured
I've successfully captured your warm-ups
I've met brilliant my baby are always be
really voice rolling well this blessing
is immerse anyone anyone out there who's
like wants to be a voiceover actor
follow his lead I'd just be recording
immediately and we're gonna do a funny
version of something before we did that
borderless there was a was a moment was
the early warning session and margarita
mix and in Hollywood it was the student
we recorded most of that game and
they're famously at Friday's after fire
Friday's after three out come the
margaritas and if you have a session
booked from you know two to six on
Friday you might want to move her home
because you're gonna get hammered and
there's my great margaritas but in the
morning they make these brilliant
burritos and so I've gotten a little bit
early and I was outside and and came in
as like how I'm pre oh so I'm eating
before my session we start getting over
Borderlands and
there's one line where Reese goes I just
feel that and I gave this purpose likes
so I guess I was the burrito and then I
kept going to the line and Pierce or
Matt and Nick Herrmann were like got it
moving on when what it was like that's I
can't wait to animate that that like we
there's no way we can like that's some
[ __ ] that the other people who are
fearful would be like well we can't use
that because he burped in the middle
clearly Kate you said and they saw the
opportunity so when you look back and
you go see all the Lance
very well perfectly right I said I will
love that I will save it I'll also
Austral way to redo it just because they
for you get that as well because what
you can't animate a bird
you know technology and we're not there
yet but knowing ps5 maybe with ray
tracing I think we'll be able to do it
sure well I guess the three of you
probably know the answer this writer's
indirect is often the same person when
it comes to the actual booth like I've
done my own video game writing and I
definitely do a thing where if I'm
writing something I'm also reading it
out loud to try to pick show what it
sounds like and I feel like handing that
off to someone else to then direct it
seems seems so weird because I'm like
but I literally said out loud how the
words are supposed to sound in the scene
you should pursue do you like that
writes is like you should there's
there's an always a bit of trepidation
when even when the first time I work
with my coach like ooh okay let's see
how this goes are you gonna be precious
with your words because they're your
words because you would like I know
exactly how this is supposed to sound a
lot of times a writer who goes other
than a writer that you direct that you
you interpret it and there's this
conveyor though mentality of like I've
done my job my job ends with my
performance that's why going back to
your thing I would have given a better
take when I first started working with
Neil I think I'm told the story before I
would run around to video village which
is where the monitors were they would do
playback and I would ask the person who
was in charge of playback just show me
the scene and I go I've got it okay yeah
and it would run back and
wait to do another take Neal was patient
with me long enough until one day he is
we were walking to our cars after a
shoot after the shoot mind you not
before after and he goes hey man I don't
wish you go on behind the village
anymore
and I would excuse me because I don't I
don't want you asking for playback and I
went ok um clearly you don't I know you
do you're new but I need that so that I
understand what I need to fix is like no
what you need to do is trust me yeah and
he was right and now to this day I think
I'm totally sober for exact I think I've
said this exact example even working
with Kojima it was really really weird
everybody including norman would be
there behind video village and i I can't
do it anymore
mr. O'Neil broke you he broke me ruined
you for the PIO to be more productive
Ilana and my responses I was a little
bit cheeky there in terms of look in
terms of like the in terms of like the
writer/director because I guess because
I am someone who both directs all of my
stuff and I feel like I intend to one
day that's a thing that I can probably
show you do body picture it right now
sounding different to how I said it
because I like what I'm writing
something I read it out loud over and
over and over and over again which I
mostly do to make sure the characters
seem consistent with themselves yeah but
I feel like it would be very jarring
because someone else read that
completely differently how it is it is
the first couple of times it's
challenging and and you know what I'm
definitely like the whole reading I love
that's how I write I Drive my girlfriend
insane the other thing I have is I will
usually like imagine cost every role for
scripts just with like an actor I like
off TV sometimes I'm lucky enough that
she kept the choice to role and I'll
kind of write to that voice and and it's
great when you're doing something that
has like let's say an actor who's got an
accent that would be very offensive for
me to be saying when I'm doing now
acting so you want to get the the
cadence of the voice right so I do that
roundhouse the difference is I think
basically what you end up doing is you
just you put a moat in the middle of the
process you say right I'm finished
writing the script is final
it's now a script I'm going to work
just there's some mental yes you have to
still let yourself do while you're
writing of the thing but once the racin
then you just like yep I had often
rewrite I'll rewrite for actors as well
so for example with me said I've had to
change words before because they didn't
sound right in an Australian accent they
were like when you say that Australian
it sounds too floaty or whatever so they
made me change words on the fly cuz they
were like we pictured this being
American I tried to impress so like for
example John wick Troy was not the
original kind of casting for that role
Virtual Boy doctor choice bad choice of
voice actor for this podcast yeah three
three takes Troy that's what it but not
he actually usually it's it's one or two
which is great I um but note when Troy
came in it was like no this is this was
written and he was written with a very
specific kind of actors style of
performance in mind so I took it all out
I watched on YouTube everything Troy's
ever done and I got into sarees of okay
no it was good um but it but it got me
into kind of the rhythm of his his mouth
sounds the way he kind of how little
words shape and I'm quite a good other
than Patrick Stewart I'm a good mimic so
I was trying to work out what would be
what would be a good comfortable things
insane and yet 95% of that was good it
but yet again in the booth definitely
there are things where people air an
actor says anyway oh no that's that's
terrible
well that doesn't work for him it's all
there the accident so you make a you say
you make tweaks on the fly as well I say
it's a good thing to to also Mike's
credit when we got in there we spent an
hour at least with my just going just
play with it what do you want to do is
that you surprise me we tried different
accents we tried different caves we
tried different everything even though
Mike knew where this kind of needed to
land if nothing else it maybe feel like
he could have been surprised it was like
oh [ __ ] actually you know that works but
way better friend to have a Texas accent
you know as opposed to what I was gonna
do but but we've traveled around and
what we ended up with was not because
the cliche would have been that role was
to make this are making off
the roll was a New York gangster right
is a very obvious way that that would
land and that would have been the cliche
but the hour we took took us round to
something I think had he sounded like he
traveled a bit he maybe wasn't born in
you know there was there was some nuance
to that but wasn't the cliche dream and
there was an adaptation like it was it
was it was an intentional a location and
yeah but the joke with Troyes he always
does a British accent for me and I've
had to say several times like I know I'm
British actors Troy easy one to do
that's the thing American actors I
actually like the most Americans have a
lot of trouble with that actually GP
zones if TV and film taught us nothing
it's that if you're British you have a
British accent if you're German you ever
British accent if you're from Mars ever
finished accident it's like just punt to
the British accent we immediately
believe anything you it's something you
need in the toolbox right right or it is
European my favorite is my favorite is
the the kind of sort of semi blatant
classes of British accents in Lord of
the Rings where it's like all the orcs
have this very kind of cockney sort of
vibe going on versus all of the sort of
fancy people that have the much more
passion sort of aristocratic we're all
about the class system man and a game of
Thrones is fantastic very cos Game of
Thrones is like 20 different regional
accents and if you notice you know
exactly what the subtext of each of
those first wrestles wild things you're
like yeah really the flippin the Game of
Thrones which is interesting is the
audiobooks
flip it so the with the TV show they're
very much like the further north they
get there they go through British
accents further right at the north in
the book for whatever reason the actor
who did the popular whichever the main
more Joe Burns was he chose to be clever
and he did the reverse all the
northerners sound southern Sun the Sun
Northern so it's a really interestingly
and it I don't like it as much as what
they did on the TV show TV show I think
tracks by the the a British people pay a
lot of attention to accents and
since they're specific to like one town
well that's finally did lazy those you
think of sorry Troy there's always I
always makes me think of that scene in
Inglourious Basterds that amazing scene
where it's like energy yeah there is
that there in the like the pub and he's
the guy is sort of sorting his way
through the guys story to see if he's
believable and he Wiggles it all the way
down to like I said I'm from this town
but your accent they don't say they are
or whatever it is that I can't remember
spend forever since I saw I remember
being like there's the tiniest OS the
fingers regal assets that's what it is
yeah right yeah but that kind of thing
it's putting out even it because the
u.s. is so huge that stuff is all true
here but there are regions that are
ignorant to each others like Tennessee
like if you talk to someone from Alabama
they can give you that full sort of
rainbow of spectrum from like that's a
northern Carolina person that's a
southern Carolina person you know that's
a raleigh-durham triangular area accent
versus that's a Tallahassee person and
like walk their way through whereas the
whole rest of the US just goes they
sound southern and like maybe there's a
difference between Texas and the rest of
the south but maybe not you know what I
mean and just like that what does a
British accent even mean it's like I
would think maybe yeah well I do have a
realize I speak I would speak with a
receive pronunciation because I had
speech therapy as a kid so I actually
probably am the closest to a default
British accent you can get ya hear those
sounds coming in southern accent yeah
but like that's why I was I thought was
so brilliant to have someone like Sean
Bean you know Sheffield or Kent is
always from somewhere but like I feel
like there's a field so he has that kind
of hybrid not quite northern urn then
also you know not quite perfectly right
for though characters in the social
structure yeah
utterly perfect how did we get and let's
do it had an Italian actor but now that
would be a title for a podcast how did
how did we get here the best how do we
called boys or the best things ever
yeah the card it was there Sean Connery
that yeah you might be right we have
about five accents I think in Australia
and it's a weird one where I can mimic
most accents quite well but I can't do
the Australian ones because like I can't
identify the differences distinctly
enough I can tell if someone's from
Melbourne I can tell if someone's from
the country I can tell if someone's a
bogan I can do the bogan accent but
otherwise like Perth sounds a little bit
different to Brisbane but it it's so
close then my brain can't really mimic
each of them and whenever I do a bogan
accent I can only do it as a man for
whatever reason you got
it's a bug and sand but I automatically
sound like a dude not an eye why that's
a bogan constructor fleet there's a fair
amount of nuance there but I feel like I
really often get told like an uber
driver or whatever when I used to catch
you this months ago would tell me that I
don't have to just four days ago
actually yeah I get told all the time
that I don't sound Australian and I
think my answer is usually sure I think
my accents changed a little bit since I
moved but the truth is more that I think
most people just don't understand the
variety of Australian accents they
expect us all to sound like Steve Owen I
guess Australian more than I get British
that's pretty cool I guess that's our
that's just our ignorance it's like why
are you Fred but the company you know I
would always think it's the opposite
though they go I think I'm something I
think Americans just forget about
Australia and New Zealand and so it's
just like if I hear an accent that's
English but not American it's just all
British I'm amazed that it's never the
reverse Australian for me more often
than they guess British but I really do
get Boston all the time because the
thing that stands out to people is my ah
sound so I say weird or he oh it's true
and they go Boston I'm like God know
what Oh God oh dear you sir how very
dare you something I was that I that's
now from seven hours ago but when you
were talking a lot about the
about this sort of it's so disorienting
to hear it said by somebody else my own
sort of analogous journey through that
with regard to like you write a solo and
you hand it to a musician and they just
interpret it so differently than than
what you were anticipating I have to say
I had a similar initial kind of story as
yours but I have to say having worked
with like hopefully there's just more
and more chances to work with people
that are able to bring something super
while because now I've done a complete
180 where I look at it as I try to I try
to in a way write it as thinly as
possible because I delight at how much
someone's able to bring that I would
never have been able to direct them into
doing and my favorite kinds of musicians
to work with are the ones like as a
soloist which would be the closest I
think an analogy to an actor is like I
try to leave as little information as
possible in the hopes that they can
stretch their their wings you know as as
fully as it's in composer land don't
take this as a backhanded comment but in
in in composer land it's like the sign
of a student to be super intensively
prescriptive where every single nuance
is being dictated do they say about
cooking right that you are actually a
chef when you stop just following the
recipe 100% otherwise you're just
practicing but I think it's also there's
a death the difference between baking
and cooking cooking is all about
interpretation of the recipe and baking
is about the precision of yeah it's
chemistry like yeah yeah everything
falls apart
I guess Austin I wouldn't have
considered that even that well okay
here's a question so if you send someone
the sheet music for a solo when you do
that and you you know what you want this
whole piece to sound like do you give
them a tone do you give them footage do
you give them a screen shot like what do
you tell them about what you've sent
them on what that what that piece means
it depends it really depends on the
situation but I would say the thing that
ends up being most common is I'll just
I'll just clue them in I'll usually just
play for them
whatever their solo is in the context of
and that's I'll let the music speak for
itself and however knowing full well
that that is a subjective thing
automatically like far more than even
just here's what they line you're
reacting to sounds like like you said
that can that can funnel the choices
pretty intensely because you're like
they were yelling and screaming but on
the page you know there's not even an
exclamation point so it's like now I'm
now I'm really reacting to something
specific it's kind of like that but
nowhere near that narrow of a passage
but it's like if I send someone solo or
they're sitting here or I'm in a
recording studio with them somewhere and
I I put the chart in front of them I
often will say can we just listen really
quick to this 30 seconds and you and
you'll just and then whatever it tells
you I want to hear that and I'm just
trusting that I did my job as the
composer of whatever that solo is in
sort of embedded it now if it's one of
those where it's like you know like the
first few notes of journey start with a
solo cello where there is literally
nothing else if it's that barren
sometimes I'll be very specific but also
the reason it's that bearing is probably
because it's supposed to feel lonely and
so they'll just feel that way by virtue
of the fact that they're alone so I'm
like just play it and feel free to
surprise me and then you know what we'll
do kind of like with your Troi example
sometimes I'll do three or four takes
and then I'll go okay now I want to
change something but this now safety
take yeah and so it's like I always say
to them we have it it's it's it's in the
can but now I just want to change
something for fun that's probably a
stupid idea and their relaxation knowing
that we have it almost always that's the
take I end up using interesting I was
like if they live revisions not often
but part of that is that like I'm
working with people that I kind of sort
of like with Mike saying how he he'll
know there he'll do his homework and
know their tendencies or some of their
eccentricities or their their likes and
dislikes or whatever and so he'll he'll
try to lean into that in the writing so
that it's sort of catered to their
strengths and that
kind of by definition is it's less about
revision at that point as it is about
exploring like I'm not fixing something
it's just let's have fun because at this
point it's if there's a revision it's
almost always it was my fault
I wasn't clear or there's just blatantly
a typo or someone's playing a wrong note
and and it's like the note on the page
is what they played I put the wrong note
or it got lost in the software somewhere
that kind of thing
revisions are are rarely creatively
about of eyes that's sort of what I
expected you to say but it's interesting
yeah no that's not to say it doesn't
happen sometimes I'll just say like wow
actually now that I'm hearing it back
I'm I shouldn't be i should have been
recording a week from now not today
because I I this is a little half-baked
and that's that's actually not the
musicians fault because I think we had a
rare thing I literally had to apologize
to mrs. a because they were like two or
three lines in a row and something I was
having knack to read that were who which
had like entry-level word word choice
like an and whether should be an if I
know I've actually apologized the guy
was like I'm ready for you writing a
daily news show where we record half an
hour after the script is done five it'll
be like what was that word meant to be a
bit like ship there it's interesting and
I've had this and there's a specific
actor who I had this with where my stuff
often often as a writer you make choices
that are not the correct choice in like
a real English level or or even like the
right choice just grammatically because
you want to evoke something in this case
it was a character I wanted to have kind
of a a weird way of talking I just
wanted a specific wording choice and I
actually had the I'm an actor at you can
argue with me because they're like well
this isn't how you would say this is the
wrong word order for this I'm like but I
think that's a character that's a
character quirk of this character and we
we got into a little bit and figure that
out um in the end we found we recorded
it as written we recorded it as the
actor likes and we recorded kind of in
the middle it's like
choices and this is this is another big
kind of takeaway for anyone's wants to
be a director always be coming from a
place of intent rather than the place of
outcome because if you if you can talk
honestly with someone about hey this is
why this is the way it is even if they
disagree with you you can have a
conversation that can lead to an outcome
if you're just saying just read essays
on the page you're you've already failed
because you're saying that someone
phoning it in
in that case like I then got I got home
I had the audio files I was listening
back to their performance and I was like
no I agree with this guy on some of this
you know some of it says it was some of
a change it was you know this is it's a
collaboration I think I think so often
from the outside because the way we
market stuff that's the way we sell
stuff we assume that directors are
geniuses who make all the right choices
and look people go along with it and
it's how it is and I think that can be
really damaging to young people who want
to be people starting out who want to
direct or one thing it's not actually
you're a curator you're an editor you're
a you're a person bringing together the
work of other people so and that's not
false it's not false modesty it's
genuinely how you get that stuff and the
secret is if you do a good enough job
you still get the credit which is unfair
but it doesn't like you still people
still think you're clever you know how
you know the number of like jokes in my
games where I didn't write that joke the
actor I'd lived that and I liked it so I
left it in or the the or the choice in
the art which was an idea that one of
the are this one artist I have who will
always palm I can say this is Gabbie our
character alice is she will always
she'll make me she like give her a piece
of concept argue or something I wanted
to make and she will 50% of the time go
away and and you know with the last hour
of her working day because I don't ever
let anyone do overtime she'll do a bunch
of kind of paint overs of the concept
arts like make it look better in her
opinion and 90% of the time it looks
much better you know and it's like this
thing where it's like that was something
I approved it went through a process
that is the thing we are doing I went to
a creative person where I can make that
better and owners are always open to
them you know that's the key thing it's
not it's not about ownership and I
honestly I'm saying this because it took
me at least eight years of my career to
figure that out so if I can save
1 the 8 years of being awesome
yeah I always thought that I needed to
be and I learned this the hard way on on
set with with shadow of war was thinking
that the job of director is to do
everything and Steven Spielberg was the
one who said that I direct directors and
if I've done my job right I've my job is
to have everybody else feel like it's
their doing what they want to do and I'm
also similar Danny Boyle calls him his
team of directors like the people who
were in charge of every aspect and that
he thinks an actor is a director it's
the same thing yeah absolutely and I
want to be the least talented least
informed least educated least driven
person on the team that I'm at if I'm
the most I'm on the wrong team yeah harp
says I will be pushing rather than being
pulled by those around me you know
there's a great Spielberg story that
really demonstrates what you just said
from et we're John Williams you know had
wrote like for a guy that's written
piles of eternal scores sure that's
still somehow one of the best of the
best right I mean it's just et is just
absolutely one of the one of the most
seminal pieces of his and they're both
of their storied careers and there's a
great story where the whole finale
sequence of riding the bike to escape
the guys and then taking flights and all
that it's like a 15-minute queue for big
Orchestra that never stops and Williams
is the old school you know kind of kind
of I mean back then like 1981 1982 there
wasn't much you could do differently
from from today but but even if it were
today Williams has always been the kind
of guy where everything is on the stick
meaning it's conducted organically
you're not constructing it like you know
the pop album style way that Hans Zimmer
piloted where every instrument
practically is being recorded on their
own and you're building up this massive
mix layer by layer by layer you know
it's done very organically as if it was
a symphonic concert and for Williams
it's he's very sensitive to in the way
that a director is relating to an actor
like that was the performance that the
orchestra did all the thing
there and the things that the elements
jailed and came together and I like that
and I like that and mind you you know
there's not even a click track you know
he's conducting everything wild which is
where where he has a stopwatch and and
then on his sheet music it's written
like bar 75 should correspond to forty
seven point three seconds if he's doing
what is manually in real time while they
project the movie and they'll
occasionally do this thing that's this
old technique that was developed ages
ago called punches and streamers and it
was done manually back then it's done
digitally now for those that still do
this where they would take they'd have a
reel of the film that they'd be
projecting behind the orchestra for the
conductor to be watching to make sure
everything's in sync and the what they
would do is when there's a really
important cutlet if you really want you
know the big you know the moment the
bike takes off for the orchestra to
start on the theme kind of thing they
would take the actual real of the
footage and do a hole punch right in the
center of the target frame and then they
would take a three foot yardstick and do
a grease pencil from from three feet
earlier to there because at standard
frame rate three feet equals exactly two
seconds and so when you do that what
happens is when you see a two-second
count off goes by as like a blurry
grease line and then when you get to the
target frame there's a giant white flash
and so as people like Williams who grew
up on this strategy mind this technique
you know they're very accustomed to
seeing those those streamers and that
way they know exactly oh [ __ ] I'm a
little under tempo I'm gonna rush the
next two beats so we land right on it so
they're in mind now this is a 15-minute
cue that has like a thousand of those
sync points that he's juggling at L and
with the musical complexity and it's all
amazing and so they spend like a whole
day on this one finale sequence finally
they get to the end of course everyone
it's like crying and it's like this is
the culmination of the art form and he
turns to Spielberg and in his very
Williams manner he goes Steven that was
the definitive take from the orchestra
but I have to confess that there were a
handful of hits that I missed in against
the footage in Spielberg very
nonchalantly goes then we're gonna recut
the footage yeah they recut the movie
they recut the movie too
final score and he actually does that
pretty routinely with Williams and it's
considered incredibly unusual that that
happens because normally the composer is
is bet rather slave to the footage and
we're low were too low on the food chain
but Spielberg regards Williams as one of
his senior level co-captains basically
and says if you think the orchestra
performance there cannot be beaten then
we will adhere to it and we'll steal a
frame their frame there and we'll do
because bear in mind
Williams is like he's off by some
incredible fraction of a second then
you're not like it's just blatantly
wrong you know so Spielberg's like we'll
do that we'll do that sitting the cynic
in me is like Spielberg left exactly the
same you tell Williams that's worth
three million dollars that a week but no
I love that
that's a lovely and by the way can I
just take a moment because what's gonna
happen is how long is gonna upload this
and you know put a title on there about
direction Steven sellable listen I just
celebrate the fact that we we had a
different topic this is one tangent but
we've managed to stay on tangents I
almost didn't message to me oh the group
this week and was like what topic that
we want and usually like previously when
we started doing it I was giving you
guys topics in advance this time I was
like I don't think we even need them
anymore
like I just show up and we'll just
accidentally talk about something for
now I'm like like I would love for us to
talk about you know as resident
journalists delays or remakes right now
but who can actually yeah I mean no I
think for next time that's I would love
to as a springboard just on Final
Fantasy 7 reactions like I that's why I
just made to go I know it doesn't make
any sense I like because I get to play a
week's more of Final Fantasy VI by
current level of busyness is about three
hours for us but what do you find at
time I works
because I so just quickly on a fireman
sitting I never play fine balance c7
never played the Final Fantasies I was
super skeptical I downloaded the demo
and just loved it like mind-blowing Lee
this is this is if is this what Final
Fantasy has been all this time I'm not
nursing yeah no he's exceptionally told
me that since yeah so so then I went
week next week you're right Walter no by
when I bought it and I and I bought it a
week ago and I have literally only just
got past the end of the demo week
because I've been so busy this one yeah
play more but we'll talk about it next
week cuz I definitely I'll say about
this one particularly and what it means
for remakes but before we close this
episode I did want to touch on a lot of
what you guys is saying is not that
dissimilar to how being an editor works
when it comes to journalism there are a
lot of like policies and practices that
I feel extremely passionately about and
there are some editors that I've worked
with in the past who have this problem
where you start writing for them as a
journalist so say like you have a
feature or a review you're assigned you
will use language that you know that
that editor likes which i think is a
huge problem you'll do it because it
makes the job easier you will have less
arguments with your editor but you're
not thinking about an audience you're
thinking about that person it was
basically in terms of writing a review
or feature your director so you you
write the piece they haven't played the
game they don't know the research that
you've done they have not conducted the
interviews but they know the tone that
they want for this particular piece of
writing you you write a review you hand
it off and and they will always give you
the same notes of like I don't like this
word I don't like these kinds of
sentences I don't like this kind of
descriptor just as that personal taste
and I think that's like a huge problem
with a lot of editors that people I feel
like I Simon to talk about a little bit
more on Twitter but I was having to edit
once a week at IGN basically I had to
make these they were video essays once a
week that had to be on a certain topic
but I didn't always have an opinion
every week and I was getting this a huge
push that they were like you have to
make one of these a week I also had a
nautical accompanied but you know some
weeks was like I literally have nothing
to say I can't just like come up with an
argumentative essay when I don't have
anything to say so I would try to assign
write as to it and it was definitely
thing that I started doing it first
where I was like well I would
have written that that way and then I
would just rewrite what they had written
with the information they had given me
like I was rewriting an interview that I
had read to my to the way that I would
write it because I thought that was who
it should be done but I was like I'm not
even gonna speak this on camera I'm not
gonna be the one who reads this on
camera I'll be in the room while they do
it
and I'll maybe tell them to take
something again or I'll tell them to add
a joke you know something but if I'm not
even the one who's gonna be reading this
why would I change it to the way that I
would write it so what I ended up having
to do a lot of the time which is still a
challenge in itself is just changed the
format like what I was very focused on
argumentative essays it's a very
specific structure sometimes the
audience got very confused because
they'd be like you write the wrote this
like it was a fact if not an opinion you
know it gets kind of the format of an
argumentative essay you don't say I
think you say yeah which is like just a
very specific thing and they did really
well there's those pieces was successful
and I really loved some of the stuff
that the writers came up with but it
became a thing of being like okay is
this the way that my brain would write
this or is this me adhering to the
format of an argumentative essay and I
would say that took me like a good three
months which is you know a lot less time
than anything else would take because I
think writing in journalistic forms is a
much more specific repeated format but
it did take me a while to figure out the
difference between those two things and
also to try to shape out writers into
people who are writing argumentative
essays when they were absolutely not
used to that it was just a lot of like
you have to have a source for this you
can't say this without a source in the
next sentence like write this like you
wrote academic essays you cannot just
have a whole paragraph that is just
opinion you need to have a reference in
here I can't just like pass it off that
way but but very similar thing for sure
web editing in terms of journalism is a
very unique skill there are people who
adjust full-time editors I'm a better
editor than I am a writer in a lot of
cases like sometimes it's hard to figure
out the words on the page or the order
that you want to write them in and man
I've submitted two reviews where I've
been like I'm really sorry about that
last paragraph I'd I know that I could
caught it it almost kind of sounds like
a an analogy to when you're like in high
school and you're studying to get an A
as opposed to to learn the material
because it's just the system
incentivizes that you know it's all
about it's all about what is the T
sure want me to write on the essay or
what are they what do I put on the block
and you you have no idea what you're
even sort of yeah you're a good editor
won't do that to you though a good
editor will be the relationship is a lot
more I have this idea I want to write
this and then I write it and then I say
I will usually if I submit something
highlight certain points and be like I
don't feel like I wrote this very well
can you help and as soon as someone else
has eyes on it they're like restructure
easy done oh they'll tell you like this
this pieces and this is the thing I have
also done as a Netta is like this this
paragraph is stronger than the one you
have above it so swap the order of those
two it's like very simple stuff like
that yeah it's only sudden editors that
you are writing it like it's for high
school like you're writing it for that
person's approval and I think that
that's a it's a unfortunately common but
I feel like you know the Twitter games
journalism circle is starting to get a
little bit more vocal about that kind of
thing like I feel like people and
getting a little bit more strict on it
which is kind of nice to see because
it's a it's a difficult loop to get
stuck in because once you start writing
for one person a one editor everything
you do will be written that way and it
gets also getting the best out of you in
that scenario right because you're a
Europe route you're producing a bad
facsimile of what what they do it comes
back to intent versus outcome if that
person should be telling you what they
want to achieve but letting you make it
way yeah but then there's also audience
pressure where if you write for as I
like IGN people will complain if things
are not consistent and will complain if
someone gave the previous Call of Duty
an 8 and this is full of duty and 9 but
the other one was objectively in their
opinion was maybe like well two
different people wrote these so there
there is definitely this weird pressure
on media for things to seem like they
all come from one person and I feel like
I you know the last eight years I've
been doing this have been trying to
remind people sure that review was
published on IGN but that is actually
this person's review that is not just
the IGN collective review and we always
get this feedback of like well why don't
you have multiple reviews on every game
that is impossible timewise just such a
giant and also the composite of those
reviews would not be as interesting as
one of them its importance the
perspective as opposed to any pause
do you think that's a solvable problem
Ilana or do you think that's just like a
limitation of human thought that we just
can't hold in our heads the idea of
twenty people that we try and turn
twenty people into one we're trying to
turn 200 people into one like is that
just how our brains work what do you
think I kind of do you think that's how
our brains work but as far as IGN goes
it's that in a lot of cases I think that
the popular kid and of course they have
made some major mistakes but people
really want to hate them so it's a hard
thing to get through to people to remind
people that you know one person's review
is not indicative of everyone else on
the website I remember one of the most
controversial reviews that came out was
written by Joe Gilroy who actually I
think was the first person to ever pay
me as a freelancer he's an Australian
writer and he gave doom 2016 I think a 6
or a 7 and people lost their minds and
the rest of the IGN stuff also disagreed
so you're always actively along he was
wrong he was super wrong but you still
support that writer because that's their
opinion and they were the one who really
yeah so I would be like I frankly do not
agree that I would get this that's cool
but that is what he said and it is very
difficult for audiences to understand
that not everyone at IGN agrees with the
score that something was given is really
dumb to communicate I think it's well
like an review scores that's definitely
a conversation someone but there's just
so much stuff that gives them so much
more value and importance they're having
in a way is damaging to everyone like
this is a game studio like you don't
want you know seven one bad review that
makes your Metacritic yeah some cases
like one bad review can make your medic
ready to go down by like two three
points on launch day those heartbreaking
but then the audience tone the audience
don't want X they get annoyed it hit the
writers usually don't want a number
assigned because it no writer does but
the audiences actually pay so much
attention to them really saying you may
prefer not to have them that they just
can't be relieved I guess that's the
thing right otherwise they would be your
absolute vivacity ya know right it's my
promise no no one does it's it's so
difficult to take 2,000 words what did I
write about Assassin's Creed origins
like 8,000 watts or something and then
push that into one number like it's so
difficult to do you'd be like I guess
this seems like maybe a nine what
I know you did you do your best that's
where a lot of other editors help out is
a lot of like this reads like this based
on our criteria for this so it like if
the scores are almost collectively
figured out and that that's become like
a miscommunicated thing what people
think that means that your editor is
giving you pressure to choose a specific
score because they got paid by a
publisher now it's usually just this
actually reads like this based on the
criteria remember the criteria and how
you fit your words into that but no I
would trash them completely it's just
that they such a point of conversation
against so many comments they get shared
like the the scores are clearly very
culturally important to audiences I am
to developers unfortunately well very
unfortunately they are like like like if
I'm talking to like a publisher I'm
gonna go and check out Metacritic over
the last three games I'm sure when
people are gonna be talking to me they
go and check out my Metacritic right
like so it is people pay attention to it
how much do you think the industry would
change if we got rid of scores oh we
really lose traffic for sure I think
we'd actually I think it would actually
on the long run it would actually harm
games because I think in a weird way I
think I'd compare it's like say Netflix
right where Netflix has no visible they
it tells you like how why is it the
percentage it thinks is going to appeal
to you but it does they don't tell you
if anything's good or not we can't you
try stuff more I think what would happen
is ultimately without review scores
without a metric that people can rally
around I think the great so something
like disco Elysium right let's go find
out about this go Elysium I don't think
that I need a reason disco Elysium among
all of the indie games that came out a
year was so played was it was like
people noticed ill Metacritic they know
still an IGN like that's a very high
number for something indie that might be
interesting I think it's great for
surfacing good stuff where where it's
absolutely abhorrent is when you see
like you know publishers or developers
where they've where they've built
weathered like they get paid less if the
meta gory doesn't hear some yes that's
that's in practice do you think I don't
even ever see a contract like that I
don't think that those score one of the
facts of life that while they are not
nuanced like just one out of ten how is
this product of tens of thousands of
labor hours like yeah
that's it's not nuance but I also find
that generally the scores are not really
necessarily wildly inaccurate like that
you might have but you have to think in
terms of a percentage plus or minus that
you might fall relative to it but I
rarely see something that's like 10% and
I think what that's an amazing film I'd
like to get rid of all those decimals
all those percentages all that illusion
of science because you're actually right
that's a six out of ten game it's
usually six out of ten yeah and a 62 or
metacritic might be you know might be a
really good mom I think it's like nearly
a seven you know I mean like it's I
think 100 point scale I know most people
hate them because it gives me more
nuance in that score and feels less
reductive of the 4,000 once every point
is I think you should be a bit more
reductive because I think so hard
because so got a benefit disco Elysium
still captures people's attention
because they're seeing the nines and
tens
wow that's the price listen I would have
given breath of the wild probably a nine
point eight and I would have had to
round up to a ten but I would not have
it should be anyone on IGN's scale 10
means masterpiece and not perfect and I
think that's a very important
distinction 10 out of 10 games not
started to ten and then get points
deducted it doesn't work that way at all
like taken it too away because the gyro
doesn't work there are like puzzles that
are so difficult I would've been like
but it's still really close to perfect
but it's just my cells are still a game
that you should buy and then reality as
well with Zelda is no one cares about
the school that Zelda's gonna sells all
those gonna find it's all history I
think I think actually ironically given
how much we often complain about many n
DS the ones who benefit most response
cuz you're gonna buy that I think the
things that the places where scoring
matters are the really bad hyper
marketed games and they're really good
under marketed games that's it
everything else falls in the middle and
that's interesting and I just I just
want to go and play I don't think the
middling triple-a game reviews influence
sales anywhere natural lunches some
people think they do not at all but I do
want to know if the big triple a game
I'm very excited about has only got five
out of ten they know one day information
as a player all right also but I also
want to hear about that ten out of ten
indie game I
never I think that's what that's what we
would lose if those two piece of
information I think one the first one is
like a consumer beware I not use maybe
that's it maybe we should maybe all
reviews should just be boiled down to
consumer beware and maybe try this one
like that would be enough for me you
know be the - storm that's simple
because like werewolves within I think
is what they call it it's um
vo game Ubisoft it's just the game
werewolf in via really really really fun
people love it I think I gave it a six
point five I had to give it a six point
five but grudgingly off to email and
Ubisoft and being like Molly you going
to fix the problems with it I don't want
to do this but it's so broken that they
were like we won't have a finish by the
end of the week I was like I have to
publish this basically it had issues
where if you load it into a lobby
sometimes you'd be muted you'd have to
leave start a new game completely thanks
but crash assets would not load so you
wouldn't be able to see the actual
character you were playing in front of
you like major major major problems but
because people had so much fun with that
game I just got a bunch of [ __ ] for
giving it that score because they were
like there's a buyer beware but they'd
be like [ __ ] you how dare you not sell
more people who said it should be my job
to sell people games or not I don't and
I also like people ask me all the time
like should I buy this game I'll be like
well I don't answer those questions
because I don't know you I don't know
what kind of games you'd like and I
don't know how much money you want
because frankly values subjective like I
would say yeah if you're a millionaire
by every game that exists ever that's
what I would do just buy all of them
play everything except for that on that
stuff that's like cooking mama that's on
you know blockchain or whatever maybe
does that makes it sound like there's a
perception that reviews are almost an
extension of marketing like they are
they are there to sell the game and it's
like how that's a bizarre Marv though
but they like I think I think this I
think I think that's why marquise knows
god I think it's marketing but I think
there is a role for critics to champion
things I think that is something
definitely well obviously yeah - y'all
saw a ratatouille
you look at uncharted 4 that we did this
huge press event specifically for
journalists in the in Europe and the UK
where we bust them into this 12th
century castle outside of Rome because
it felt you know uncharted and even
though it takes place there but it was
everybody that went through there and
got to stay in the castle and eat at the
castle good this big event that
influenced obvious of their review
because you give the inspiration but I
was part of marketing was to get people
like otherwise in them Lea loses a
review it's they don't do them because
they very much try to influence you
mmm it's messy but a lot about what I
can see that's a great that's a great
one it's not eating sounds like an
awesome it is loving kids I love you I
have to actually jump off to go get to a
call I try and do the thing that we've
been alluding to so I hope that was
Final Fantasy damn it I'm also planning
to have next week's episode because it's
episode 10 be alive my schedule it's
actually the one that's kind of screwing
around so I will tweet when we figure
out when we can lock that in to figure
out what day we can do that light but it
should be a lot of fun I think it would
just be a cool opportunity for us to
like have a little bit of audience
interaction and week's Monday's people
live oh thank you everyone for listening
sorry that we made so many video
specific references